hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new episode of
the witching hour you know me and haley
but right now we have a very special
guest we need to introduce you to
it's ashley zuckerman one of the stars
of the fear street trilogy
holy [ __ ] it's so good it's so good
congratulations thank you very much it's
uh
i i'm uh very very very proud and it's
nice to
be in something that's well catching
fire like this and
yeah and then people seem to uh
yeah that they've really they've really
taken to it
because it rules because it rules it
really does it's not that i had low
expectations or anything i feel like
it's just
it's another scenario when you know you
get really good hard but then all of a
sudden you get something great
like something that is likely to fit
all-time status
going forward yeah i i think so i think
like i think even while we were making
it we knew that it was
well it just felt special and lee so
special and and
the group was so special but there's
like an extra element
of of what the moment is and this film
these films seem to have tapped into
something of the moment that
i think people are connecting to it
because of what the world's going
through when they see
in it uh what they're trying to express
and i think
i think that's what's giving people that
that's that's also what's also driving
the film
i definitely would agree with that
that's a big part uh we warned you we're
gonna talk a little bit about everything
right now we kind of wanted to go back
to the beginning
and get to know you a little more um
you've got a whole bunch of variety on
your resume whether we're talking about
on-screen work or stage work so when you
first pictured yourself
making it so to speak in the
entertainment industry what did you
picture what was kind of the end goal
on day one of your journey i i i think
that um that those goal posts
have changed so many times and and what
that
might look like uh yeah it kept being
very new for me i think at the beginning
it was
well i just didn't know i i i might i
don't come from a um
a family of uh creatives and so
this this world was all very new to me
um i knew i i wanted to be
part of it i very much you know loved
the camaraderie i loved the
making the making of things but i i
think i knew very little about it
um and then uh
now it like at a certain point it sort
of became clear that
like making it just meant
being able to choose the jobs
and always try to be at the center and
feel like you're at the center of making
something
that um to be with other great people
and just all
trying to do something together that
that seems like and if i could do that
from job to job to job that's the that's
what's special
you mentioned you don't come from a
family of creatives so did you have a
particular experience
did you see a particular film what was
it that pushed you in that direction
no that's changed it's it's very funny i
even that's changed in in recent years
like what what my perception of
childhood and why i wanted to do this i
think for a long time i really just
thought
it was um i
i really just had a i was worried that i
probably wanted to get into it because i
was
chasing attention or something like that
was my perception of uh like me as a
as a 12 year old thinking like why would
i
why was this something that was
attractive to me and then i think as
i've
as i've gotten older i think uh you know
i think
our family was very academic we were
very
very cerebral and i think
that there is a truth to express
something i think that's that's probably
what it came down to and
so getting into it that's what i found
in it i don't think i was able to
articulate it at the time but i think
once i started doing it i thought oh
that wow this is an opportunity to
actually
speak to everything that's going on
inside me and actually you know
share it but and then and then it it
became a little more
serious and then and then i you know i
found a love of actually telling you
know stories that
stopped being about me i think i hope
so what what would you call the the big
break
the the project or the gig that kind of
made you go
i want to do this to i am here and i'm
doing it and i see a real career for
myself going forward
i was studying i am out of high school
and i
i was very lucky i went to a high school
where there happened to be
it did there probably shouldn't have
been but there happened to be this
you know very energetic and very
inspired drama teacher
who like really like was
who was prolific he he made us do
like 12 productions a year and he
organized these tours so we would get
together and
actually tour to england and japan
performing at other schools and and and
that was
and that taught me a lot about just the
rigor of it and
and and what and and you know speaking
back to the camaraderie of what can
happen in those environments
um and but but i still didn't believe
that it was something i could do for
for life um and so i went to university
and
studied science and engineering and then
kept auditioning for the local
conservatories but you know
still didn't think i was i was going to
be doing this
and then even got into one of the
conservatories and
um and and when i started i really did
think when i graduated i'll
maybe try for a few years but i'll
probably return to engineering
and then out of it i i was i was
just sort of very you know that there is
a luck
component and and uh i was lucky
to be able to quite quickly learn
through doing it
and so you know there was a big american
show that came to town
called the pacific that i was you know
very lucky to be
be a part of and then through that i
learned and then that led to something
else like something else and then
um but in terms of i think you know the
first time that
i i thought like i was giving given
something that was so
right for me and and a real like
test was a show called the code in
australia which was
um a political thriller in the style of
more akin to what the british had been
doing or the norwegian or the
nordic um thrillers were
and uh and that was a really special
experience so i'd say that that that
really cracked open something for me and
and showed me a new way of working and i
discovered something new and then that's
because i think that's in a way the
beginning of this
of the next trajectory and me loving
this
the craft in me really going back to the
pacific briefly because
that is a gigantic hbo production and
that's one of your very first screen
credits so what's something that made
you go
like holy [ __ ] i can't believe this is
what it takes to make
a production of this scale when you
stepped onto that set
you know i i i couldn't fathom it and i
was so green i was
so green and you know i was just i
you know i just come out of three years
of uh college
of art school and i was just trying
everything
trying to bring it to life and and when
what is
taught at
or what i was taught at school did you
know it
it it takes a bit to free yourself of
that or for me to
free to free myself from that study and
find what actually is real and what
works and um and and uh i was
i i was uh i was in a daze for uh for
most of that it was it was a
a very rapid uh education process
it was also an interesting project
because although like there was an
ensemble of like a 150
core cast or something like or like
maybe like 60 in the center of it and
then 150
um getting bigger and we there was a
boot camp and and so that introduced me
to a
style of working that was you know very
very different something i was wanted to
be a part of not a boot camp necessarily
but an immersive kind of experience
it occupied me for years after i
finished that project
thinking back to all the moments and
thinking back to what it was and
and uh it it took me a while to like uh
to be able to actually understand what
it was that was happening and be able to
actually
know what the experience was like you
said that enormous ensemble and massive
production
was that a circumstance that really
reframed your understanding of what it
can mean to be an actor
in in film and television production do
you think you fully had a grasp on how
big it could be i don't think i could i
could grasp it i i i really
there was at first there was so much
that was theoretical like i was i think
22 23
when when i did it and like
we'll we'll hopefully we'll talk about
like fear straight in those
young actors and i mean all of them
they're they're unique
and they and they're generous and they
just like
they work completely from what's true in
themselves
at at all times and and it took me a
long time to learn that
i that that is not something that came
came naturally i'm still learning that
and
and that's you know i was i was carrying
a lot of like ideas about what what it
was so so you i came into a
thing that was that big and it was just
more noise because
i think i think beautiful work can
happen when it's that big and when it's
just
you know a couple of friends and a
camera i think you can
make great cinema in both ways and um
and it took me a while to figure out
what the
what the uh what the essential was what
what it was that
is actually our job and you know and
to be completely just like ourselves is
you know
is the job and then that's what i find
so special about those
younger fair straight actors that they
just they seem to be
have been born with that and that's a i
was in awe
around them i know you said that the
search for that kind of continues and
evolves still as you go along but is
there any particular project or
collaboration that kind of gave you the
biggest nudge forward and
started to let you tap into that i think
the code was a big thing for me
personally in terms of it just gave me a
way of working and it opened something
up for me
and then and then um
and then i went a few months later i was
casting something called manhattan which
i
i met haley out in santa fe on
um and i thought oh this is what i
wanted to be
um all the time that i i think
i i you know if if i spend any time like
looking back over
the tapestry of what has led me here
like the singular threat is that
whenever like there was
um you know a really rewarding
experience it was because i was
i was cast despite myself that whatever
it was
that the creators or the i mean
the wealth of talent around is is
enormous that on
on the great projects it's not about who
can
who can uh act at the best or who can do
it the best it's about
i really believe that it's about who has
the soul that they need or who is the
right
um that that that thing or that
the experience and whenever there was
one of those projects
and that ended up being really rewarding
like manhattan
um it was because i was cast because
they saw something in me that they
needed for that specific story and it
would take me years and maybe i didn't
even realize during
but only afterwards why it was that it
was me everybody who
listens to this show knows that i still
never shut up about how great manhattan
is i
love that show there's a there's a
special place in
all of our hearts for for those early
champions of manhattan
it's good and also check this out i just
was rubbishing through my shelves and
like what i found
oh damn what a flashback um
yeah it was very special and it was a
perfect storm
that allowed the show to happen that
probably allowed them to even cast me
and then probably for that same
reason that's why the show couldn't
continue like we it was
an a very i i think a very early
victim of this transition of network of
cable to
something else i think if streaming
didn't happen and
cables kept expanding maybe maybe they
would have continued but that one that
that hurt that one had
it makes sense it was a phenomenal show
but i will say it helps
because it hurts me from a different
angle to not have seen the future of
that story however it helps that really
the core
cast has kind of gone on to really blow
up in certain capacities like
everyone is doing great phenomenal work
and i don't know off the top of my head
who the casting director was but man
they did
great work beanie bacharach yeah what
what uh
what a group like what what an
astounding group of people that they
assembled when
um and some of us were were a little
known
but but generally like they they brought
together a group of essentially unknown
people to inhabit this thing and
uh i'm obviously olivia williams john
benjamin hickey and daniel stern very
incredibly well known but then the rest
of us
you know still really just starting out
and they
yeah and now and uh and everyone's doing
such such
big beautiful stuff yeah haley finally
encouraged me to start the binge and i
have and i would have finished if i
didn't move this week but in case
anybody out there wants to binge
manhattan the whole thing is available
on hulu
download it and take it with you on the
plane just like i did great
it's very it's very special yeah it's a
really special thing and it does have
and even though we just got to do the
two seasons there is an ending
um it would have been lovely to find out
where it goes but
there is an ending of sorts it's not a
it i i think we did
it does complete a story
for sure you might kind of touched on it
a little bit but something i was always
fascinated about that
um was wgna was
like a like you said kind of stuck
between two eras
of tv yeah and a short-lived network
that put a lot
into their productions you know when we
were there on set they're gorgeous built
sets and i'm curious from the the actors
perspective the performers how
aware were you of the transition that
was happening in the industry and how
sort of unique it was
what they were trying to do on that
network if like the last year especially
has taught me anything is how
incapable i am to assess what's going on
in the world
at all and like the like
uh the inability for me to actually see
the what the short-term changes will be
but i when we we were starting out and
netflix
was just i mean house of cards had just
come out and they were only now starting
to and
and and at the same time wgn launched
their own platform they had moved from
like a very small
uh local station i believe like it was
known for playing cub
chicago cubs games to now like putting a
lot of money into development
and um we we didn't know
but we did think that what
perhaps naively and maybe why was so
hard that
that show ended like it did was we just
thought we were
immune to the gods of hollywood that
that we just thought it was
it was just so special and the work that
was going into it and
the group we had we really just thought
how how in the world could this
could could this not not go on so i
personally was very blind to
how well that was moving it happened
real fast
it's like this yeah and it and it'll
keep happening fast i think now we're
even seeing this
uh the war of the streaming networks
where we're gonna
i imagine in a few years see only a few
remaining
and where everyone's trying to vie for
power
well even fear street's journey to
streaming has been
something even different yeah and i and
i
listen to the uh your lee's interview as
well
which i i'll spook that back i highly
recommend anyone to
download that and listen um
yeah exactly this was originally made
for fox and with the
with the view for it to be a theatrical
release and then
um and then the merger between fox and
disney happened and then it was never
really
a disney never made to be a disney piece
and very luckily we ended up on netflix
so make me giggle a little to think
about the possibility of this
under the disney umbrella i'm very
thankful that that did not happen
me too yeah is fear street and the wind
the only two horror films you've ever
been a part of yeah i've been in another
thriller but
essentially yes yeah is there anything
about the wind and working with
emma on that that you found coming in
handy when jumping into fear street
not ah that's interesting not
particularly and
for me even in the way lee
would talk about it with us and the way
we worked or maybe it was just where
nick solomon sat
is that it
it never felt for me like we were doing
a horror film
there was just something so real at the
center of it that we just
kept or that i just kept playing
into that i guess it gets a little a
little crazy towards the end and that
was
it's funny i haven't had a chance to
actually talk about it
without revealing anything finally i
have
my chance to tell my my story my story
um but yeah it it it's funny
it just never never felt like that like
and that's the
the genius i have and it's something i
don't understand i don't understand that
i i there is no way i could ever make
direct this like that like the the
understanding to
like to lay layer the the gravity and
the humanity which is i think where
like where we live with with everything
else it takes to build
a great horror film like that's a that's
a craft i i
couldn't begin to understand
understandable again i think this is
next level content here
before we jump into fear street full
force do we want to touch on succession
at all because my job was to binge
manhattan and hayley's job was to catch
up on succession
you haven't done succession yet i'm a
mad person i don't know what's wrong
but it was incredible i watched it in
like two days oh my goodness
and as much of a horror film as as
anything else
no kidding um yeah
a very just a really special thing to be
a part of and
yeah you know and also just a very
unique experience and there's something
that
like on all of these great yes like uh
manhattan
succession fear street the the through
line
towards all that through all those
things was um
yeah that i i was cast i think because
of something that i was not in control
of and also that
the experience of making them a unique
that it didn't
none of them felt like the others and uh
i think that's a testament to the to the
creative process to the creative minds
who are trying to who
who put it together you going through
all your credits too it's also
incredible how many things that you've
been a part of with such exceptional
ensembles like they're they're all
like next level ensemble pieces too
which i don't know i find
very fascinating and like a probably
like a wonderful opportunity for you
yeah and very enjoyable um i don't know
how much
control i've wielded over the things
that i've been like
luckily to be a part of but i
for some reason i do think uh
those people who do choose to include me
in the their shows
include me in a in a type of show i i
i've been it's not that i
haven't i haven't auditioned for other
kind of work it's just i'm very lucky to
have
like been included in this stuff
something that really
stood out to me watching it within the
span of like 48 hours
is uh i would watch it
like episode there were some episodes
where i was behind and i wanted to watch
it
and i don't watch everything that i i
wanted that i really wanted to watch
and and i couldn't do it i liked it
there's some episodes where i just felt
too sick
um yeah well that's kind of i mean
it's a lot it's kind of what i'm saying
these people are so much to take and i'm
curious is there
like how do they direct you when you're
saying despicable things and the
audience needs to stay on board like how
do you guys
approach performing these characters
that some of the dialogue you get that
all these characters get it's just
real real nasty stuff to say to another
human
but you are sucked in and you love
watching these characters
when i was there it's sort of amazing
how
how loose it felt and i mean you can
feel it i think in in watching it that
there's so much freedom and there's just
i think the writing is so strong and
then they
just allow so much they set it up in a
way that there's just a lot of freedom
um and then all they
and that just sort of creates a very
loose environment and and i think
something else they do
there that's so special is that they're
just kind of
they let something just unfold and then
they keep interrogating it and then they
if they have alt lines and they just
keep throwing in
new things that they
there's they just don't have a lot of
they don't worry about judging that
spending much time judging the
characters and i think that's what
that's what maybe makes it
special it's it's it's trying it's
another it's another one of those things
it's like trying to understand
a magic i have a lot of love for the
creative process and and i have a lot of
faith in it
that the environment often makes the
thing
and i think on all of these great things
it's the creators
um and they're jesse armstrong who just
creates a
very special environment and and
that carries into the thing my other
succession question
is what is like what was your favorite
part of a
as a performer playing in that world of
these like
snakes and vipers and that dynamic and
what was your favorite part
of uh filling out the dynamic between
nate and shiv
well what's what's lucky that um
i've known sarah for years we're both
australians
out here and um and that was very
special in terms of moments
later on when it gets pretty spicy
between
the wine bottle scene with matt and
um there are a few like that that gets
quite
quite ridiculous but it's very funny
there seems to be like a
quite a big nate hate
going on and um i always thought he was
a kind of a good guy
so i just thought he was just like
trying to connect with someone he he
loved it
and and maybe yeah it's so i thought
yeah it's a difficult
one i don't know how active we were in
trying to fill it out
i think we just were having a good time
doing that and then the story just ended
up doing so much for us
i i think that on the scale of secession
characters nate is definitely one of the
gooder guys
like it's odd
the people who put him high on the hate
scale i i feel like i worry
for them a little like that's a it's
like i don't know what kind of a
what kind of a human being fears him
more than the others
i think about that wine scene very odd
like just like a part of me
dot like and it's appropriate that this
happens but a part of me dies inside
just
watching him go through that right smack
in the middle of a room full of people
yeah and yet him deserving it
and can't argue with that
yeah how how uh how difficult is it to
pour a glass of water
i do wonder about that
i think maybe that's the most stressful
part about that
what happened to your shoes
that part was actually kind of strangely
i was actually surprised at
how easy that that part is so if anyone
ever wants to save their wine like
but if you're done put it back in like
it's actually
got to all right fear street
fierce great all right so starting at
the beginning of that i'm curious how
this project was
first pitch to you like the very first
description of your character you ever
got and also the very first description
of this production process which
is another very unique thing about this
trilogy it's interesting
i i was sent i was sent a script
um and i was sent to sides
and the sides were what would end up
being
lee janiak nick good
solomon good sides um and the script i
got was an
earlier draft it was from a team
prior to lee um
and the two didn't really match the the
but the script was
fun but it was i think probably
i would describe it as just
more fun oriented rather than actually
uh trying to speak to anything or it
didn't
it it was just sort of using the
the nostalgia it actually felt a little
more goosebumpsy than it felt
um like like fear street and
not sure if that's fair it it was but
but it was it was just uh
it was just a very different piece and
but the sides were really rich
and they and uh and so i did i i i sent
the tape
and lee had seen it and she was familiar
with me already like
i think she said in the your interview
with her with and she had seen manhattan
and um something connected and then we
met
and it was only there that she actually
described the
fear street universe as she understands
it the
the how the three-time lines work i
didn't know nick
was who he ends up being um
when we started i i think
that first iteration was more
you know i think when this sort of
carried a little bit
but we play with a trope in the first
film that like is he the
uh the the
the unknowing cop that might turn around
might come around and join join the kids
or might be helpful in some way i think
there's
there's a rare adhering that we just
sort of should try to play with a little
and the first iteration it was far more
that
that than anything um and then
and then lee told me what it was that
these
films were and meeting lee and just
seeing
what an original she is and like
how she talked about and what it was she
wanted to make and then that's that's
when i was
all in i i i left and i i just told all
my
my reps like please like whatever
whatever it's going to take whatever's
going to go on for me please
let's just make this happen smart move
there
good move strong man um but we just got
on really well and we talked about and
it was also interesting how
and i think i i don't know if uh lee
mentioned it
lee hates auditioning she she hates the
experience of it i think because she
doesn't
like uh i i think because she doesn't
like
putting people in those situations she
doesn't like any she doesn't like
power dynamics and and she doesn't like
it when there's
uh i think that's why i i should ask her
about that but
she just knows exactly what it is and
what she needs and then she sees it in
people and then wants to
add those people to the to the
collection and she it's just
trust her instincts so much pretty
incredible it's very interesting did you
ultimately have to do like any chemistry
reads at all or did she go full instinct
that was it it was just the initial tape
and then the meeting
and and uh and i was shocked because
that's not
that wasn't typically where i was at
career-wise
um and i i absolutely expected to
that there would be more rounds to this
but i think she she just knew what it
was that she wanted
um from this and that was it yeah
got that vision so
you jump into filming 1994 first
what was it like i don't know if there
was any workshopping involved or any
conversations you had with lee while you
did this
trying to figure out how much of nick's
truth to pepper and throughout
that film because it's a thing where you
watch it the first time and i'm pick up
on any of that
then after i watch the full trilogy and
i went back i see little hints all over
the place
right we we talked a lot about it we
really like one she
it was plotted perfectly like like
to be able to put three movies together
and think you've reached the end of a
movie even like the trick of
knowing you thinking you've reached
understood nick's story at the end of
two
is like quite a magic trick and that's
so it was plotted incredibly
and and then it was
and then we just talked a lot about how
we play that yeah it was unlike anything
i've ever done because
we we that that was also a
responsibility it wasn't as simple as
playing something
as a truth we we had to be conscious of
of keeping that secret alive and yet
tell yet giving enough
other like playing into enough other
tropes and also the audience is just so
sophisticated they if this film was made
30 years ago we could have done
something
like it would have been a different set
of rules that we'd be playing with but
everyone is looking for they know the
tricks they know what they're looking
for
and um and we and so absolutely we were
trying to toe the line and and at the
same time we also didn't want him to be
um bland we couldn't make him be nothing
we we
we had to offer something and it just
yeah and i i i am i am glad you s
you say that because and that's i think
something i'm
i'm proud of that we i think in watching
it back
it does still track both reality's track
pretty well and that's um
yeah so something we did have to just
work on pretty sure
that i mean like being able to pull
something off like that requires like a
next level amount of nuance and i think
you definitely nail it
yeah we're i'm lee and i were texting
after the second movie
came out and we were like
i i don't think anyone knows i think
we're good
i didn't i mean we always talk like
spoilers and theories right after every
single installment comes out i didn't
see many people throwing that one around
after 94 or even
78 for that matter yeah and what i mean
it's it's really a leap what an uh
uh yeah it's you had me going
most of the time through 1666 as well
because
there is such a strong chemistry between
you and kiana that i couldn't help but
to want
like even though i knew that wasn't the
path she was on
like i wanted like some semblance of
relationships
to work between solomon and sarah
because like it felt like they both had
holes in their heart and just like
needed help and i wanted them to have
that help from each other
yes yeah
yeah i mean well i'm to piggyback off
that i think it's
the to me the most impressive thing is
that you keep that ruse going until
almost the very end
of the 66 or you know at least the end
of the
portion 766. um because you had to pull
that trick off twice is what i'm trying
to say
with two characters back to back
shooting back to back
how did you approach your prep process
for these two characters that are so
thematically related with the same
actors and
main you know and the physical endurance
required to shoot it
yeah there's it is interesting and
you're right because the thematic
storyline is the same like between them
both they're they're both
and horrible things start happening
and they have to live through those
things knowing that they're responsible
for those horrible things
and um i'll solomon
solomon first was
there's something it's not something we
we kept talking about was
that like although you know i
this is like i i don't really i don't
know what that
phrase is but you like there's this
adage you have to love your characters
and and i think that's like that's a
nice
like trick or thing to remember if you
have trouble like identifying with bad
behavior but i don't think i have
trouble with that i think you know
there's
we are all multitudes like
like we have most human beings i think
have that there's a spectrum of like
potential bad behavior so like i i i
typically don't have trouble like
engaging with
something lee and i talked about is that
there would have been a cynicism
in in either character being
um completely
not feeling the events that were
unfolding so solomon
as the reality of what the pastor
does unfolds and he gets faced with that
reality
like that is
whether that's guilt he it's something
he feels and it would have been
too arch if he just also didn't feel
anything about that so there are things
he feels i'm not
saying that that's anything akin to
empathy we need to have like like that's
not something that we need to like
feel sorry for like but but but i i just
think
that there is
genuine feeling about the events that
are unfolding and i think that helps us
advance that lie for as long like to
keep the lie alive
i i say that like genuinely
i don't need any empathy for any of
these two characters but they
but but in terms of helping us advance
the
the lie then uh that then in that that
way that that is helpful
um and and so i for me so solomon emmy
he's he's the originator of this thing
that he
um
you know whatever came over from the old
world this he didn't come up with the
idea of
um of
putting of using other people or of
like um
sacrificing others for the benefit
of himself like that that's that's not
new
but he did um
but he did started he he started it
again here and he thought he deserved it
and i think he was just too weak to
actually see another option
and so he actually ends up being the one
to to pull the trigger just because
it's something that he deserved being a
little lost
hopefully this is a hopefully this is
all interesting um
well yeah um and then and then nick is
just the the person who has to
keep it going and that's another
experience in itself
he he's the person who's blind to the
realities of those situat of the
situation he's someone who just doesn't
have to face
the fact that um that
those in society who have the dice
loaded against them
he would believe that that it's still
their fault that they're in this
situation that they can't rise out of it
themselves
um and so that was the
approach to that i think of
clock in my head it just felt like i was
talking for too long
um i just i just think we're talking
about all this stuff to the right people
though
you could probably sit here mesmerized
for hours
i i just think that there is like an
important subtle difference between the
two one one is just the
the the person who who
who came up with it and the other is the
one who uh perpetuated it and
and both of those people are interesting
to
to think about because they they are
around and
like especially those who perpetuate
this reality this dynamic in our society
is something that's
that's very real and i think there's
something that like while we
kept the lie
alive like i i feel like what's
satisfying about these films and
definitely when i read it
was that it just makes sense like when
it ends up
that it's nick and solomon and then nick
it's just it's just that's the only way
this thing could have ever gone
it has to have been it has to have been
that
what about the difference between i mean
solomon or nick
seeing the death that they cause versus
when nick puts his hand on that beating
heart at the end what kind of
discussions did you and lee have in
order to make
that moment feel feel different because
you know we only get to spend that time
with him for you know a
couple of mere seconds we don't really
see him like fully process it to the
extent of you know
let's say alice in 78. so what's going
on in your head playing that beat
yeah so so i think there's a few there's
a few like interesting levels
to to like so nick nick is like like in
in one way
he's just someone who wants the status
quo to stay exactly as it is he doesn't
want anyone to
to try to change anything that's his job
that's what's been put on him
and if anyone ever tries to do anything
a little different
he needs to kind of shut that down and
then
and then when dina
when when the group seems to
be very close to unraveling his reality
like it's all just fear and anger that
kicks in
and he all he wants is
it it's very funny and that's something
i think we see often and i
you know whenever there's a new level of
you know when ev every time i think it's
something that we see that whenever
those in power
feel like that there's that power is
being taken away from them a little bit
um there's a knee-jerk reaction against
it all based on fear
and it's and it's angry and and
that is what happens in nick it's it's
first it's a it's a it's an instinct to
control it and then there's an instinct
to um
to it to be enraged by it to be
threatened by it
and then there's the uh and then putting
the hand on the
beating heart of evil that there's an
extra level which is uh
um you know well
it's it's cathartic in a way it doesn't
end that way for nick but
like it's the mental game of thinking
like what if
all those people who are perpetuating
this
division in our society had to actually
experience the pain
that they've been caused whether they're
the ones who pulled the trigger or just
the ones who maintain it
if they had to actually feel that pain
um
what would happen and um and so that's i
i think what it was that we did to it
not
like in in the film as a punishment in a
way
but also as as i think a catharsis for
for everyone for them for us for for
hopefully the person to actually
yeah to make make
make those who have been trying to hang
on to power for so long
um suffer it suffer the pain
that's so true a very good way to put
that um
i'm looking at my lengthy list of like
real geeky spoiler questions right now
another thing i'm
curious if you discussed it with lee at
all is the goods
selection process how they pick who they
wind up possessing like for example ryan
at the beginning
um yeah it's
well i think well i think solomon picked
the pasta because
he was just it's just jealousy and the
pastor was the is the most senior person
in the town
and uh and the person who's also and
also i think solomon woods
thinks he's an outsider i think he
thinks he's got big ideas you know that
that like and he thinks he's an esoteric
when in fact he's just not he's just
he's just nothing
and um so he he
chose the person who was attacking him
he felt he was attacked by the pastor
being like
the head of the this very exoteric
power base and so i think that's why
solomon chose him and then
uh and yet nick chose ryan i think i
we did we did talk about it
i i can't remember exactly i think it
was something petty i think
also nick just has a very petty like
view on like why he
like why he keeps bringing martin in
i think he just like like ryan just
said the wrong thing to him at a traffic
stop and uh
and that was it i think that's like
he just felt a little threatened and
that's all it took
i very much believe that this is a
little bit of a silly question
but do you think that any of the goods
compare the slashers they created like
is nick thinking like you know
skull mask is way better than nightwing
or or not nightwing but ones that came
before nightwing
that's that's good
there was a bit when lee she didn't know
exactly what she wanted to do with it
where we kind of like
play the history of the goods like this
kind of dread we
we very quickly did some uh uh some hair
and glasses and things
and we tried to kind of play different
characters through the timeline and i
think some of them were bigger creeps
nick's a creep but like more more uh
like aware creeps
i think nick just believes himself just
so blind that he just believes himself
to be a good guy i think
uh i i think he was just really shocked
i think
nick was just yeah that's good
this is the kind of stuff i think about
that made me curious did you guys talk
at all like what what is the dynamic in
the
good family like what's a christmas like
at the good family resident
we talked a lot about like what
generational uh
evil looks like and also generational
trauma and how those
that the past influences the present and
that's
that's everyone and um
and that nick's father was
probably very very overbearing and uh
you know and pl
and put this responsibility on and nick
and we see it we see him he's just such
a
like he has no idea who he is in 1978
and he's just grasping at straws
and grasping at anything that feels real
which is ziggy
and and and so i i think for me i think
it was just that like he's just lonely
like he nick just been lonely his whole
life he is
he never he could never talk to anyone
about this
his brother probably knew but didn't
like knew that something was up maybe
but like
felt out of it um so i i just
i don't think that they were rejoicing i
don't think they were all celebrating
this thing and all getting into the
witch's outfits i think that they
uh i i think it was just a dark place it
was just like
it was just gross i mean that house that
they made
that dean and sam
the dean and sam kind of come up into
isn't yeah did you get to go
uh into that set at all i did i didn't i
i was
already done by the time they shot that
i feel like even though
like you very quickly and easily get a
sense of what that entire house looks
like i still want to explore every like
yeah
they did such a good job and actually
like there's some in the background
there's some
there's a few photos of um uh
matt who plays my brother and i like
that they needed photos of me uh that
they wanted to put some photos of
young a younger nick and i i just didn't
have anything in my
out like in my photo stream that looked
anything like anything that would be
appropriate so matt and i
just took a camera and went out and
played golf well we didn't even play we
just took a golf buggy and we just
thought golf was
the most perfect uh like synergy of
what's everything that's wrong with
these people
and so we just got in our like brightly
colored polos and
and took a bunch of shots of us playing
golf
they're really brilliant i don't think
many made into it but they were yeah we
took a lot of photos of us just playing
golf
you should share those on social media i
should yeah yeah i should
i'll go find them one of my favorite
like
moments of character transformation for
you is the scene where you're really
having it out with sarah in 1666 you
know the hands
um but i'm curious the transition
between
this sort of like desperation and
solomon
and his his you know trying to tell her
that he loves her and to try to bring
her back around
and then the moment he decides that's no
longer
an option and switches into he's going
to give her up to people
he's just so fragile like he's gotten he
he just has his like his trunk is just
so thin he's got not like the wind just
blows
and he's just ends up being so reactive
and i think that's
there's just no backbone in him at all
that so
he feels rejected he's scared and he
lashes out and he ends up like
grasping at straws which is to try to
like
pull and pull uh
sarah towards him
and and then uh
and and and then he does what what he
has to do to protect himself i think
that's just
i mean i think that's the through line
of the good characters is just like
the fear that they have of of
being found out and being of their power
being taken away
and i think that's what goes on there
that and they just grasp with straws but
they don't feel
anything like i don't even know like
what if sarah
said yes to him like what would that
relationship look like like
like what kind of a man would could he
be
like or a partner like what i i
i think he it was just it was just him
acting entirely out of fear
that that progression yeah interesting i
was gonna ask if
you thought it's you really loved her
that sounds like a hard no
well i think he would say so i just
don't think he knows what love is
i think i think he
he absolutely feels that i think he he
would identify something and it would
like but he doesn't
i don't think he could put that together
like same with nick i just don't think
he
that they're both just little little
boys like
yeah before our last two haley i do have
one more fear street question
did you guys ever discuss incorporating
the fact that
that nick needs to continue the lineage
and maybe peppering that throughout his
journey in the films
you know we never talked about that but
i did think about it that it was
interesting that he was
he hadn't started that process and i
thought that
that was i i did think that maybe that
was
like that was the one redeeming quality
i didn't think he needed
like nick himself
needed to feel conflicted about what was
going on
um and and that maybe a part of him
didn't want to pass this on
that's just again
we have no need to enter into any
empathy for
these characters at all but that but
that but for
playing it i think that's um that that
was true
so there wasn't maybe and i thought it
was interesting that he was just a
single bachelor living in this
ridiculous house exactly what went
through my mind with nick and
like i know we have a full complete
story in this trilogy here
but i i would be so curious to know
solomon's next steps especially
after what he went through with his
family like he obviously continued the
bloodline and
i don't know just between what you
described with
feeling some guilt over seeing what the
pastor did what he went through in the
past with his family coming to the
decision to continue what he's doing
for future goods versus just making this
something that benefits himself in the
moment
there's there's so many little details
in there that i think would make
any good story worth exploring even
further absolutely oh i feel greedy no i
think i i think that's
like in a way we also have that story
like that's the story of america like
having like
white men have to have gone through like
you know
uh slavery oppression of women um
the witch trials and then and then have
to
keep living for another 300 years and
maintain that
that that like that's that's the story
of solomon good after
after that moment like uh like whatever
has to happen
to be blind to the actual pain that
you're causing or like
maintaining like that's that's the
that's the story and it's it's horrible
yeah that's a ridiculous like whatever
what an understatement
horrible fascinating and i mean i i
can't get enough of these movies like
again i i know we've said it before but
congratulations on fear street to you
and the entire team
i think i can speak for haley and that
we are both obsessed with these movies
yes do we want to try to squeeze in our
last two before we let ash go
yeah that you watched the episode lee
you know what's coming
i did yeah i actually stopped when it
said like we do these two questions i
heard the first question
and then i i went no i'm not gonna
listen to that i'm gonna
get the second question live i've never
had a pet
growing up we we never had any pets and
then
um a year ago in the middle of the
pandemic
um i was living with um some family and
uh it's sort of it's sort of this uh
like a brown but it's like a few
apartments and there's other family in
other floors of the apartment and there
were rats
in the basement and because covered all
the restaurants shut down so they
weren't putting their rat poisons out
suddenly there were more rats around and
um
and uh so there were rats in the
basement and then the family decided to
think
to get uh a dog to
solve the rat problem and i said you
know i think that's a pretty reactive
situation but my voice doesn't carry
much weight
and so they but they decide on their own
not to get the dog
instead they got a kitten and
like i i don't know anything about
kittens or cats and i didn't back then
and then
um it turns out kittens do nothing
against rats because
they're smaller and then so then the
kitten ended up being put
on in our apartment
um and then we were the kitten was
forced on us
and and until that point i didn't i i
didn't
understand cat people hallie i know
you're
you've got you both have cats do you oh
i had i had the same problem as you
though
right and i didn't like i didn't
understand
cats i didn't understand the people
talking about their cats
and i have never my like opinion on
something has never
switched so rapidly so quickly and now
so now we have this kitten um who's a
year old
i i think we're maybe still allowed to
call it a kitten and uh
yeah that's what so that's that's what
we have what's the kitty's name
lyncher so the dog's name is
serious this isn't good the dog's name
is bobby
the cat should be called babalene and
it's lean
lean [ __ ] for sure this isn't great this
is incredible that's terrible
oh it's great for us we love the pet
talks
that we do yeah that that's been that's
been my last year
i i i can't believe it like i actually
this
this little thing i really i i'm i'm
a little blown away i'm delighted you
came around same thing happened with mom
by the way she was not a cat person
moved in with the cat obsessed
yeah i 100 get it i was a dog person my
whole life and then i finally got a cat
when i was living in manhattan
and it changed everything the surprise
second question for you
if it's something you've seen lately or
revisited just anything in
genre that you love a film a book or tv
show that you would recommend people go
check out
yeah i i so i i
have both um not a great
cinnamon knowledge um and so but at the
beginning and also definitely not genre
i've never that been that
uh like enthralled um
but i um did i just
lose the interview like that's now just
cut they you cut me off just before that
um that but um but i did like at the
beginning of the year i
started giving myself sort of a cinema
education and um
and there were a few that in terms of
like genre like thrillers really get me
badlands is something i saw which
i still think about uh uh
you know yeah i i just say badlands
terence malik's badlands
it's remarkable like how that story
moves and what happens it's really
very strange and scary and
excellent i will take that all right we
gotta let you go now but again
thank you for hanging out with us and
huge congratulations to you
thank you so much thank you all right
everyone that is it
you have officially survived the
witching hour
you